like everyone else in the world you've
probably caught soccer fever minutes
till the US takes on Germany the only
problem you have a job well an
enterprising group of Americans has a
solution for you a national holiday and
they've petitioned President Obama for
just that their pitch is simple worker
productivity nationwide is going to drop
so why not just make it official save
the country from long lunches sick days
and endlessly refresh browsers they
actually have a point in the last World
Cup we saw Wall Street trading volume
dropped by 43 percent when Team USA
played in the heartbreaking - - to tie
against Portugal nearly 23 million
Americans were watching at one point
while the president isn't in the
business of granting new holidays the
petition should it reach the hundred
thousand signature threshold to force a
response will land in an administration
rife with soccer fever Vice President
Joe Biden attended the opening u.s.
match against Ghana and was downright
Biden asked in the locker room after go
Team USA the President himself released
a vine routing the team on shortly
before kickoff the soccer fan in chief
travels to Minnesota the day of the game
but aides say he'll be getting constant
updates on the match if not slipping in
some time in front of the TV like he did
at the g20 in 2010 in the end the
president may have a very real incentive
to give the country a holiday unless he
wants the White House to run without a
staff the market with the highest
viewership in the country during the US
Portugal game Washington DC